thank you very much for joining us we
begin this news hour in Algeria where a
court has sentenced two former Prime
Minister's to long prison terms for
corruption amid Ohio Yaya was sentenced
to 15 years and his predecessor Abdul
Malik salon 212 the charges came from
sweeping investigations into fraud
allegations after the former president
Abdelaziz Bouteflika stepped down in
April
let's bring in Hashim Albuera who's
covered Algeria extensively for us here
on al Jazeera Hashim a significant
ruling that comes just two days before
the election tell us first about who's
been convicted and why fully it is quite
significant
at the same time it's unprecedented you
have three people widely considered by
the algae algae Ria's as the main
pillars of the political elite in
Algeria during the time of former
president Abdul Aziz batavia who was
ousted by the mass protest movement in
the country receiving heavy sentences so
this is unprecedented Mahad
the first one is Mahad Bush Arab who was
Speaker of the Parliament and he
receives twenty twenty I think twenty
twenty twenty years in in jail and also
we have Ahmadiyya here who was Prime
Minister four times and he's widely
criticized by the Algerians and accused
by being one of the masterminds of the
many years of embezzlement of public
funds and corruption in the country Dell
Medicus ll was also Prime Minister twice
in Algeria during the time of former
president Abdul Aziz but a vehicle at a
certain point who was one of his top
advisors close to his brother as the
aside Bhutto fleeta and he was one of
the key architects of the attempts in
the past so try to perpetuate the rises
with Africa's grip on power for many
Algeria's these were the people
responsible for the problems that the
country is continues to face and I think
this is quite a politically motivated
move it wants to show the Algerians that
this new political establishment is
adamant about the need to turn the
chapter
of the many years of mismanagement and
embezzlement of public funds interesting
and unprecedented as you say because
it's coming just two days before a
contentious presidential election which
the protesters people who've been asking
for this establishment of political
establishment to leave have dismissed as
an illegitimate attempt by by them to
consolidate their power how they then
receive this verdict well it's to me
this is quite obvious that this is
attempt by the political establishment
in Algeria to appease those Algerians
who are not going to cast their votes in
two days from now because they say that
they went to the streets in February to
not only remove Abdul Aziz Bhutto Flicka
but the whole political establishment
that has in one Algeria since 1962 they
say that the political establishment of
the political elite does not work for
the country they need something
different we need vibrant genuine
democracy however there were
disillusioned because when the asset
president Abdelaziz Bouteflika they
ended up creating a weird situation in
the country that consolidated the part
the military strip of power
general guide Hamas Allah is the most
powerful man in Algeria now and they saw
some members of the old elites still in
power for example Badawi who is the
prime minister in Algeria was interior
minister during the rallies multiply and
they said wait a second this is not what
we were aiming for we were aiming for a
new political elite in Algeria the
political government or the political
elite which is in power now is very
concerned about a lower voter turnout if
that happens let's say that only 15% of
the Algerians cast their votes in two
days from now the next government is not
going to be seen as legitimate
this explains why you're seeing those
sentences today they want to convince
the people to go to the vote and they
want to tell them you know what we are
clear-cut
about the need to turn the chapter of
Isis but a bloody spot of Lehi and his
legacy and those who served under his
command and those who are responsible
for the mismanagement will definitely go
to jail and they will spend the rest of
their lives on long sentences so I think
this is part of the whole deal they want
to convince people that was happening in
Algeria and
the presidential elections are the
beginning of a new political chapter in
the country however I have to say not
many Algerians are convinced all right
thank you for that Hashem Hashem al bara
with the latest there from Algeria where
again two former prime ministers have
been convicted and imprisoned for
corruption in a landmark trial as well
as a former parliament speaker thank you
very much Hashim